herzlich willkommen wir melden uns mit
zdf heute live denn in ungefähr zehn
minuten werden in berlin zwei flugzeuge
landen und das wollen wir uns gemeinsam
mit euch live anschauen
deswegen auch unser blick eben auf das
etwas noch trist aussehenden rollfeld da
und wir schauen dass an nicht weil die
flieger so besonders wären die das sind
ganz normale maschinen von easyjet
beziehungsweise von lufthansa sondern
weil sie mit neun jahren verspätung
landen also die flieger sind verspätet
sondern der flughafen auf dem sie landen
der bgr drei buchstaben die für ein bau
aus stehen das seinesgleichen sucht
nicht nur in deutschland
die brandschutzanlage mangelhaft die
automatiktüren haben nicht funktioniert
räume sind aufgetaucht die gar nicht im
plänen verzeichnet waren
dazu kleine müllcontainer falsch
verlegte kabel also da wurde wirklich
gar nichts ausgelassen und am ende hat
es nicht nur viel länger gedauert es hat
auch viel mehr gekostet dreimal soviel
6,4 milliarden euro
deswegen wird heute auch nicht groß
gefeiert bei der eröffnung des br
sondern ja um es mit den worten von
flughafenchef engelbert lütke daldrup
auf den punkt zu bringen der sehr
nüchtern machte wir machen einfach auf
corona hätte es wahrscheinlich eh nicht
zugelassen
es gibt also eine menge zu besprechen
heute während diese flieger landen
wollen wir das tun mit unseren
korrespondenten und reportern vor ort am
flughafen in einem der beiden flieger
und mit einem ausgewiesenen flughafen
experten und kritiker der vorgänge beim
br
ich darf meine fragen stellen sondern
auch ihr schickt uns bitte gerne eure
kommentare eure fragen alles was ihr
wissen wollt auf zdf heute live im zdf
de das ist die entsprechende e mail
adresse also ende gut alles gut trifft
es in diesem fall nur bedingt das finden
auch zahlreiche anwohner taxifahrer
klimaschützer viele haben heute einen
protest angekündigt verschiedene gruppen
aus verschiedenen gründen
deswegen ist auch vor dem br heute
einiges los unter anderem steht dort
unsere reporterinnen und unsere
studioleiterin in brandenburg nicola
albrecht nick oder hallo was ist denn da
genau los ich höre schon und sehe schon
hinter dir die spruchbänder
die demonstranten sind relativ
eingefunden aber vielleicht erst mal
vorneweg die stimmung hier heute ist
tatsächlich passend zur geschichte des
flughafens 14 jahren nach spatenstich
heute also nun erster touchdown im
nieselregen mitten in der korona krise
ich bin heute früh schon gegen 8 uhr
hier gewesen und habe mit den ersten
neugierigen besuchern auf dem
willy-brandt-platz gesprochen und auch
mit mitarbeitern und ehrlich gesagt hat
sich bei allem nicht wirklich bei allen
nicht wirklich partystimmung
durchgesetzt sondern die meisten haben
eben gesagt na ja wir sind froh wenn
dieser tag vorüber ist wir sind froh
wenn jetzt diese flugzeuge gelandet sind
und wenn der betrieb dann mal
aufgenommen wird ganz anders geht das
hier den aktivisten die meisten von
ihnen sind tatsächlich klimaaktivisten
das heißt sie sind hier um gegen die
eröffnung des flughafens zu protestieren
weil sie sagen in der großen klimakrise
einen flughafen mehr zu eröffnen noch
dazu einen großen macht überhaupt gar
keinen sinn da gab es verschiedene
aktionen blockaden hat man hier versucht
um den sozusagen eröffnungs betrieb ein
wenig zu stören es haben sich auch zwei
aktivisten hier schon abgeseilt von
dieser empore hinter mir
die wurden dann von der polizei
allerdings auch wieder runter geholt und
eine gruppe
am boden bleiben die haben sich heute
hier als diener verkleidet also
zumindest viele von ihnen bei der
pinguine neben der vogel ist der nicht
abhebt der nicht fliegt er am boden
bleibt und beim heer corona technisch
etwas auf abstand ist frau strauß klarer
strauß sie ist die pressesprecherin und
ich würde ganz gerne wissen von ihnen
frau strauß was ist ihr großes anliegen
heute hier bei der eröffnung vom br
unser anliegen ist zu zeigen dass es in
zeiten der klimakrise totaler wahnsinn
ist im neuen flughafen zu eröffnen das
der größte skandal des br nicht die
kurzen rolltreppen sondern der eröffnung
eine kapazitäten erweiterung es halt in
der klimakrise ist und unser anliegen
ist es dass flugverkehr massiv reduziert
wird beziehungsweise das jetzt nach der
korona krise eben nicht zurück geht's
zum business as usual sondern in andere
klimafreundliche technologien investiert
wird der herzlichen dank ihr sprechen
vielleicht gleich noch einmal
das war ein erster eindruck es gab auch
noch weitere demonstrationen heute
morgen hier unter anderem auch von den
berliner taxifahrern
denn die sagen sie wollen allesamt
nämlich 7000 taxifahrer insgesamt hier
zum wr potenzielle fluggäste bringen
dürfen bisher haben aber nur 300 taxen
die genehmigung dafür also viel ist los
gegen den br aber aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen niedrig vielen
dank für den augenblick wir schalten
gleich nochmal zu dir wir haben noch
einiges zu besprechen jetzt wollen wir
uns aber erstmal anschauen welche themen
überhaupt heute ja groß sind an diesem
eröffnungstag der an mayer hat für uns
den überblick
der tag beginnt mit protesten
klimaschützer wollen die eröffnung des
flughafens stören
der airport berlin brandenburg willy
brandt sorgt für geteilte meinungen
gegen die erderwärmung etwas machen und
das machen wir nicht wenn wir hier
riesige flut leben lang es wird zeit das
ja auch gemacht wenn jetzt noch das
ganze vernünftig läuft und wie auch
endlich wieder fliegen dürfen
ja und wie ist das schön
los ging es vor 14 jahren nach
gesamtkosten von etwa sechs milliarden
euro geplant waren zwei milliarden ist
der pannen flughafen heute endlich
fertig rund 10.000 freiwillige testeten
ihn in den vergangenen monaten die
mehrfach verschobene eröffnung ist kein
grund zum feiern mehr und die
schwierigkeiten hören nicht auf
die pandemie ist ein schlag ins kontor
für die gesamte luftverkehrs wirtschaft
die größte krise seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg
die spüren wir auch aber wir haben einen
sehr starken markt und wir haben einen
modernen flughafen wir werden am ende
geld verdienen doch für das kommende
jahr hat der flughafen chef bereits
staatliche finanzhilfe gefordert in
einer woche wird mit tegel der letzte
flughafen auf berliner stadtgebiet
schließen überdies und mehr wollen wir
jetzt sprechen mit einem fachmann der
den flughafen anfangs sogar mit geplant
hat inzwischen zu einem der
entscheidenden kritiker geworden ist zu
den vorgängen die zum flughafen werden
jetzt geführt haben nämlich dieter
faulenbach da costa schön dass sie bei
uns sind mit welchen gefühlen beobachten
sie jetzt diesen tag
ja ich sie haben es ja richtig gesagt
dass ich am anfang dabei gewesen bin
beim standard zu verfahren beim
raumordnungsverfahren und später beim
privatisierungsverfahren leicht noch mal
arbeit immer mit gemischten gefühlen
weil ich aus fachplaner überzeugung
heute noch sagen es ist der falsche
standort aber der wurde 1996 entschieden
und dann bin ich darauf fassen wenn man
dann entschieden hat sind durch alle
gefahren durch bekommen hat sollte man
ihn dort auch in betrieb nehmen und
sollte sich überlegen was man mit dem
flughafen machen kann ihn nicht in
betrieb zu nehmen wäre was meiner sicht
ein fehler gewesen
sie sagen der falsche standort ist das
auch der grund warum sie sagen da
eigentlich sind die gar nicht mit neun
jahren verspätung jetzt gestartet oder
starten jetzt sondern
im grunde mit 20 jahren verspätung war
schon in der planung ganz am anfang
falsch abgebogen wurde
es wurde 1996 politisch falsch
entschieden von den drei anteilseignern
statt einem vorgeschlagenen standort
sperenberg den flughafen zu bauen an dem
es keine lampe betroffenheit gegeben
hätte an dem man ein flug mit sex pisten
hätte bauen können und der 24 stunden
betrieb der daten können ist man nach
schönefeld gegangen und hat gesagt der
schön flughafen schönefeld soll die zwei
innerstädtischen flughäfen wegen lärm
belasten der bevölkerung ersetzen
der flughafen schönefeld wird aber
zukünftig auch mitten in der stadt
liegen das heißt aber die dreifache
lärmbelastung auslösen und damit hat man
keinen gewinn gehabt sondern eher eine
verschlimmbesserung das heißt man löst
zwei flughäfen auf mit wenig verkehr
konzentriert den verkehr auf einen
flughafen und belästigt die dort
betroffenen bevölkerung mit dem
dreifachen flug lang
das macht aus meiner sicht keinen sinn
warum hat man sich denn damals dann für
schöneberg entschieden
da gibt es natürlich viele vermutungen
und einem einer oder meine vermutung ist
der damalige bundesverkehrsminister
wissmann saß im aufsichtsrat von
flughafen frankfurt und des flughafens
münchen gehört gab beide auch den bund
mit und der bund hat an beiden flughäfen
geld verdient und er wollte nicht noch
einen dritten flughafen die wollten
nicht nur einen konkurrenz haben und vor
allen dingen der damalige lufthansa-chef
hat deutlich gemacht wenn in sternberg
gebaut wird einen flug mit sex ist
möglich ist sieht lufthansa mit sack und
pack nach berlin um
und da wären fluke die flughäfen münchen
und frankfurt provinzflughafen geworden
etwa in der größenordnung des flughafens
köln bonn und das wollten die natürlich
vermeiden und so haben wir dafür gesorgt
dass erst der falsche standort kam und
dass zweitens bedingungen für diesen
standort dann definiert wurden die dazu
führen dass der flughafen sich niemals
als konkurrenz für den beiden flughäfen
entwickeln können wir sehen hier
übrigens auch die ja die das
begrüßungskomitee in den live bildern
die ihr seht ihr auf dem auf den
bildschirmen
eine große feier gibt es heute nicht
aber ein bisschen feierlich soll es dann
doch zu gehen
die feuerwehr wird glaube ich auch
gleich wasser spritzen und an bord
dieser beiden maschinen sind auch die
beiden
chefs der fluglinie easyjet und
lufthansa spur und lundgren wir sprechen
bis die landung erfolgt noch ein
bisschen weiter man kann nicht
vorbeikommen über die kosten zu reden
6,4 milliarden euro drei mal so teuer
wie wie ist das entstanden sind das nur
die die baukosten gewesen
die baumängel mai nicht gewesen kommt
übrigens gerade entschuldigung da kommt
gerade easyjet einmal würde ich gerne
sagen man kann natürlich die mitarbeiter
verstehen dass sich darüber freuen dass
endlich eröffnet wird gerade in zeiten
der krise
das gibt den perspektiven die sie auch
brauchen dagegen gleich weiter denn
jetzt gerade der patsche wollen wir doch
aber noch mal in voller schönheit das
ist der erste offizielle touchdown auf
dem neuen hauptstadtflughafen
easyjet ist
viele an der auf unser reporter carsten
behrendt links sitzt der den br und die
entwicklung seit vielen jahren verfolgt
und hier sehen wir auch geballte
prominenz unter anderem haben sie
gesehen den verkehrsminister scheuer
dann sind natürlich die
ministerpräsidenten von brandenburg
wollte und von der lieben der regierende
bürgermeister müller natürlich dabei
denn schließlich haben wir hier gleich
drei staatliche bauträger den punkt das
land werden
wie verfolgen sie jetzt nun diese diese
landung sagen es gut dass es stattfindet
endlich und ansonsten wäre es eine
normale landung wenn jetzt schon ein
kleines wunder um licht werde aber
ansonsten ist eine normale landung
gewesen und finde ich gut dass endlich
stattfindet muss ja auch ein bisschen
was klappen sollte es wenn alle augen
darauf schauen wenn sie sich jetzt
versetzen in den flughafen chef und die
crew die da jetzt natürlich für alle
sorgen muss was ist jetzt nur der
wirkliche lackmustest wo liegen jetzt
vielleicht noch die dritte allen die an
diesem tag heute also gut vorbereitet
des und wegen des geringen
verkehrsaufkommens an diesem tag ist es
ja wie flughafenchef mitgedacht abgesagt
hat wir nehmen in betrieb nicht den
gesamten betrieb sondern wenn der
betrieb mit erstmal wieder in den
flugzeugen und damit kann eigentlich
nichts mehr schief gehen das ist vorher
getestet worden
und da denke ich mal da sind sie
professionell genug zu am flughafen
sie haben lange noch flughafen betrieben
um zu wissen wie meine flughafen künftig
betreibt und zwar auch konfliktfrei
betreibt zumindestens mit diesen
verkehrsaufkommen an diesem tag und
denkmal der rhythmus geschichte ich
glaube seit august sind 900 leute im
einsatz sieht das ganze schon simuliert
haben jetzt ich denke mal auch die
werden da auf nummer sicher gegangen
sein hier kommt übrigens gerade eine
frage von einem
kann sie auch explizit wer ihrer meinung
nach den größten fehler gemacht hat der
zu dieser ganzen verzögerungen geführt
hat die frage ist wie schon häufig
gestellt worden
da kann ich nur sagen nur fehler war der
falsche standort und dann haben zu
dieser diesem desaster alle beteiligten
beigetragen nämlich planer baufirmen
flughafen gesellschaft und politik
und da will ich nicht unterscheiden wir
jetzt das größere desaster werden
also ich glaube das ist auch einer
dieser ganzen probleme dass es so viele
verantwortlichkeiten gab dass man auch
niemand wirklich mehr festnageln kann
oder ein problem war natürlich um die
verantwortlichkeiten zu klären oder mal
etwas zu durchschlagen dem
beispielsweise number kölner
philharmonie
dort hatten sie einen anteilseigener der
stadt hamburg
in berlin hatten sie drei anteilseigner
bin unterschiedlicher politischer
ausrichten auch dazu die sich nicht um
grün waren in jeder eigene interessen
verfolgt hat aus die bestimmten
interessen auch als bundes oder landes
interessen heraus etwas anders wollte
als der andere wollten und da war es an
schwierigen gemeinsamen interessen zu
finden und beispielsweise die
flughafengesellschaft und die baufirmen
und planer zu norden um den zu sagen was
es zu tun haben das war nicht immer
einfach bundes nicht immer gelungen
es hatte ich sie eben unterbrochen weil
da gerade nun der touchdown stattfand
wir hatten gerade über die kosten
gesprochen und die frage ob es wirklich
nur die baumängel waren die das ganze
dann am ende
sarah war dann die baugenehmigung 2007
wurde ein kernel beantragt zur
baugenehmigung beantragt dass von 1998
stammte
die verkehrsentwicklung die ja
inzwischen dramatisch war der zuwachs in
berlin dramatisch war nicht
berücksichtigt das heißt 2007 wurde ein
turner genehmigt dass schon das
verkehrsaufkommen das jahr 2007 ich
hätte bewältigen können und das war der
ausgangspunkt für die diese für die
mängel weil man dann statt jetzt zu
sagen wir stoppen plan neu ans flughafen
das nacht agiert den zugewinn verkehr
bedienen anstatt schon den jetzigen form
nicht mehr
hat man den termin aufrecht halten hat
gesagt wir planen erweitern und planen
um die fehler die wir bisher gemacht
haben während das pausen das war genau
der hauptstadt flieger kommt diesmal von
der lufthansa aus münchen kommend ja man
hat ihn passend zu diesem tag also
umgetauft wie wir sehen und auch dieser
flieger wird es das ganz normale
prozedere durchlaufen was wir alle
kennen als fluggäste das dauert ein
bisschen bis man dann tatsächlich
aussteigen kann
es gab damals ja auch mehrere angebote
mehrerer haben gesagt ja mindestens eine
milliarde muss man auf den tisch legen
dafür aber man hat das angebot für 620
630 millionen genommen hat man sich da
schon von anfang an in die tasche
gelogen führt ich weiß nicht ob man sie
die tasche gelogen hat
fakt ist dass diese ausgaben zum bau des
eines betriebsfertigen chemnitz
von vier generalunternehmen angeboten
worden die etwa 11 milliarden haben
wollten und die flughafengesellschaft
hat den aufsichtsrat gesagt es kostete
das terminal bahnen wir für 620
millionen
da wäre jeder aufsichtsrat in die
öffentlich verprügelt worden wenn der
dann noch ein auftrag 33 500 millionen
delta zum angebot der generalunternehmer
und eure eigene fahne und euro
flughafengesellschaft wir bauen für 620
millionen dass in dem an die in der
kostenkalkulation der
flughafengesellschaft der flughafen
spezifischen einfahrten in die pads oder
am rand und gabel und grund dass man
noch sogar noch gestillt war so nur
mittels reine gebäuden mit erfolg kann
man nicht erwarten einen ausschuss nicht
den normen des bauwesens kennen und
stellten die berechtigung kleinen vorne
passiver blog senden
da muss ich auch seine geschäftsführung
verlassen wo die geschäfte sagt ihr
basis versetzung des franz millionen
musste
einen sozialpakt das lässt an falsch lag
250 millionen in der kostenkalkulation
des vorstands gezielten wissen anderes
thema das kann man dem ausland lassen
sondern es nicht mehr ändern
der flughafengesellschaft in den banana
lassen dass sie empfinden
passend dazu schreibt uns bitter
dietmar man auf facebook herzlichen
glückwunsch zur eröffnung und
gleichzeitigen insolvenz da spielt er
sicherlich auch darauf an dass jetzt die
teams auch immer
die passagierzahlen
wie gesund sind und man wird berlin
wissen
diese 100 millionen
vielleicht sprechen während sie hier die
bilder haben wie beide maschinen dann
langsam zu ihrem date folgen
die lufthansa ist noch auf dem rollfeld
thema baumängel
es war wirklich alles dabei sprechen wir
erst mal über das größte ding das war
sicherlich die entrauchung sun lage das
große ding im wahrsten sinne des wortes
sich doch man hatte sogar das monster im
land zwischendurch weil damit mit so
vielen problemen zu kämpfen war was war
da los an sich ja ein monster ball und
gegen den gesetzen der physik in teilen
des gebäudes graubner und abgeleitet
wurde durch kanäle dann erst nach oben
glücklich wurde abgezogen darunter
weitergeleitet wurde
aber die 1000 anlage als monster genannt
war das in das schaufenster quellenpark
und afrika klären von wo man zwei
fahrten trefflichen geprägten heute
nennen sonst 2012 erklären müssen dass
hat der landesrechnungshof brandenburg
geschrieben dass der flughafen ist zu 75
prozent fertiggestellt werden während
brauchen so anlage war es selbst
gestellt
die halbfertige am ball gekonnt diese
fehler mängel die 2013 glaube ich beim
auftauchte zu 60 das sei der weg der
flughafen war nicht betriebsbereit 2012
wo man hätte der öffentlichkeit erklären
müssen wir haben wissen dass apple
karten des männlichen stellwerk juni
platz gestellt ist haben wir eingeladen
alles gemacht und müssen jetzt zugeben
wir haben uns geehrt nein da hat man
gesagt die anlage ist schuld denn die
mängel waren wir noch viel mehr das band
die kabel kabel asien das waren die
brandschutzmauer bis waren
brandschutzwände es waren die fehlenden
funktionalen anordnung check fehlender
check in counter und alles was dazu
kommen darüber sollten die laien
mülleimern und zu kurzen rolltreppen
auch noch alles möglich und das war das
ergebnis dieses dieses fehlers der mann
2007 2008 gemacht hat mit einer falschen
überholten genehmigten planung hat ja
eine baugenehmigung wir anfangen zu
bauen
und während des baus das terminal zu
erweitern und um zu planen und um zu
planen und die planungsfehler
gleichzeitig nach dem mann gemacht hatte
zu beseitigen das führt zum chaos und
hat dann letztendlich dazu geführt dass
man 2010 so meine informationen 2010 die
kontrolle über die baustelle verloren
hat und danach hat auf der baustelle
jährigen was er wollte und das war dann
2012 das resultat was zum aus bekommen
wir können nicht den betrieb nehmen und
das war das resultat hätte man besser
machen können ich sag mal lütke daldrup
2013 als flughafenchef hätte das
sicherlich schneller gelöst aber
zwischendurch hat fachleute gegeben und
kein politiker will total body das will
ich glaube man hat dann 2030 sogar wann
war ist 120000 mängel 4000 davon sogar
genehmigungs relevant festgestellt und
man hat ja sogar gesagt mensch oder es
gab stimmen zumindest die gesagt haben
eigentlich müsste man das ganze ding
einmal abreißen und neu aufbauen würden
sich das unterstreichen oder war da
schon der richtige weg tatsächlich
weiterzubauen am bestehenden gebäude ich
habe kann ich mich noch gut daran
erinnern im september 2012 gesagt eine
stange bilder mit würde für mehr orten
sorgen als auf der baustelle besteht
hass und hab dann hinten drangehängt hat
gesagt dass termin entkernen und neu
aufbauen wer der bessere der schnellere
und preisgrenze weg als jetzt zu
sanieren wäre wahrscheinlich der bessere
weg gewesen hätte man sagen können
man nimmt das terminal dann den
flughafen von 2015 in betrieb und hätte
wahrscheinlich dann wenn nur ein bis
zwei milliarden mehr gekostet und nicht
mindestens vier bis sechs milliarden
jahr wie man heute feststellen
jetzt hat natürlich auch das ganze geld
gekostet um es überhaupt diese bauruine
die es zwischendurch ja war oder die
baustelle überhaupt zu erhalten also wir
sprechen zum beispiel diesen geisterzug
den berühmten der durch den
fertiggestellten bahnhof gefahren ist um
es zu belüften schimmel entsteht was
muss auf seiner baustelle gemacht werden
wenn es so lange dauert es gab ja neben
diesem geisterzug auch noch die
parkhäuser die vor dem kreml stehen die
die flughafengesellschaft durch dritte
hat bauen lassen sie wollen genau weil
da war einmal kurz wegen gleich weiter
weil das doch dieses schöne bild das
inszeniert man jetzt natürlich auch dass
die beiden flugzeuge da aufeinander zu
wollen ich schätze mal man wird auch
gleich darauf achten dass man ziemlich
zeitgleich dann die türen aufmacht und
aussteigt an bord die beiden chefs der
fluglinien johan lundgren von easyjet
und carsten spohr von lufthansa die
haben es sich natürlich nicht nehmen
lassen bei diesem großen tag dabei zu
sein
da sehen wir etwas was im normalen
flugbetrieb nicht vorkommen da erklären
sie uns warum nicht dabei auf dem
rollweg begegnet das darf nicht sein
entweder man hat immer ein bahnverkehr
auf dem rollweg und auf einem rollbett
zwei flugzeuge begegnet geht nicht da
muss ein flugzeug so lange warten bis
das andere flugzeug vom häufig ist haben
sie heute den verständnis für diese
schau was da passiert
und dann legt nicht an die passagier
brücken an das heißt die testet man noch
nicht sie meinen die kurbel sind die man
dann durch geht sondern dass ich außen
per treppe jetzt jetzt ist auch noch
nicht mal eine außenposition sollen sie
halten auf dem auf dem vorfeld troll
vegan und bleiben dort nase an nase
stehen was sicherlich eine ziehharmonika
eröffnung ist viel gesagt im
normalbetrieb ein ding der unmöglichkeit
ein wort vielleicht noch zur auslastung
dieser beiden flüge die sind natürlich
heute nicht ganz voll
zum einen weil man jetzt natürlich diese
zwei besonderen flüge hat ein flugzeug
ist übrigens in tegel gestartet hat eine
stunde in der luft verbracht und ist
noch mal über den alten flughafen
gekreist und hat den kurs genommen auf
den neuen flughafen unser reporter
carsten behrendt 40 gleich erzählen wie
das denn von da oben alles so aussah und
wie es sich angefühlt hat die wollten
uns aber gerade erzählen was nötig ist
um so eine baustelle überhaupt dann ja
am laufen zu ich höre gerade wir können
mit unserem reporter carsten behrendt
schon sprechender ist ausgerüstet mit
aller technik die man dafür braucht er
sitzt ist klar sie sehen es noch im
flugzeug hier dann also das wovon wir
vorhin gesprochen haben die
wasserfontäne von der flughafenfeuerwehr
das ist ja das übliche prozedere immer
wenn man was feiern will da gibt es
diese schönen fontänen carsten behrendt
an bord des easyjet fluges auf der
rechten seite hier im bild zu sehen wenn
du uns schon hören kannst
nee das ist die collage die wir im bild
sehen aber carsten wir hören dich
immerhin schon die feste in den flug
über den alten und den neuen flughafen
in berlin
ja es war natürlich aufregend ganz
wichtig erst mal festzuhalten wir waren
jetzt wirklich die ersten dieser
parallele anflug hatte aufgrund des
wetters dann nicht geklappt die
parallele landungen
es war war es spannend dass ich hatte
persönlicher und kloß im hals als wenn
tegel losgeflogen sind weil ich
natürlich auch wie viele berliner sehr
starke emotionen mit diesem flughafen
verbinden
das war quasi wirklich eine verbindung
vom alten zum neuen wir sind relativ
früh über die wolken bekommen sodass er
von berlin eigentlich relativ wenig
gesehen haben was ich dann allerdings
über den wolken gesehen habe ist dass
eine zweite easyjet maschine die
verfolgung aufgenommen hat der lufthansa
maschine und dann merken wir hier gibt
es auch einen konkurrenzkampf darum wer
hier die nummer eins künftig am ber sein
wird easyjet die die nachfolge von air
berlin angetreten haben oder in die
lufthansa und das ist jetzt noch einen
kleinen trick ausgedacht
easyjet mit vielen flugzeugen
tatsächlich vor ort durch corona
ausgedünnt ich glaube von 34 flugzeuge
die man eigentlich dort stationieren
wollte erstmal auf 18 runtergefahren
darüber können wir gleich dann auch noch
mal sprechen
carsten du kennst dich aus mit dem br
bericht es seit jahren darüber wirst
gleich für uns auch natürlich die
abläufe testen als einer der ersten
passagiere durch und durch das ganze
übliche prozedere geht darüber kannst du
jetzt noch nicht natürlich berichten
aber du kannst sagen wie die abläufe
bisher waren am flughafen es wurde ja
denn die schon fleißig geübt was ist da
genau gelaufen wie hat man sich
vorbereitet auf
es lief jetzt nach der baulichen abnahme
die von einem guten halben jahr erfolgt
ist ein langer test mit komparsen mit
freiwilligen insgesamt 10.000 tester die
diesen flughafen und seine abläufe auf
herz und nieren getestet haben parallel
die schulung von tausenden mitarbeitern
vom flughafen und auch von den airlines
und dieser test ist offensichtlich ganz
gut abgelaufen
der braucht diesmal etwas koordinierter
als damals 2012 also es waren deutlich
weniger bautätigkeiten da noch parallel
so das das ich aus meinem augen stand
eigentlich gesehen aber das ist ganz gut
funktioniert hat es wurde dann auch
geübt hier mit flugzeugen das geguckt
wurde passen die überhaupt an den bh das
hatte man mir vorher noch nie probiert
br mit flugzeugen ist er tatsächlich
eine neuerung die wir jetzt haben auch
bei diesem test sind einige dinge
aufgetauchte die noch nicht gepasst
haben aber ich habe mit den leuten an
bord gesprochen
alle probleme die aufgetaucht sind die
konten offensichtlich dann auch noch
abgestellt werden und du warst natürlich
auch schon vor ort im flughafen nicht
als offizieller passagier aber angeguckt
hast du es dir schon die geschäfte dort
machen jetzt natürlich auch auf an
diesem wochenende sind das die üblichen
flughafen geschäfte die man so kennt
oder gibts dann regionalen einen schlag
hat man sich etwas besonderes ausgedacht
was erwartet die passagiere daten also
es ist so tatsächlich ich war schon beim
spatenstich 2006 dabei und dachte in
fünf minuten fünf jahren macht der
flughafen auf daraus sind jetzt 14
geworden und seitdem war ich immer immer
wieder fürs zdf dabei jetzt auch beim
ausbau der geschäfte es ist ein bisschen
anders als an den
an anderen flughäfen hier hat man darauf
geachtet dass es bei den geschäften
viele regionale anbieter gibt auch
wirklich kleine läden die hier das
experiment flughafen wagen und das ist
auch gleichzeitig ein problem denn die
haben keine so dicke kapitaldecke und
einige von denen hat halt dieses ganze
desaster halt wirklich übel zugesetzt
viele sind jetzt trotzdem an den start
gegangen einige mussten leider aufgeben
also wir sehen sowohl bei der
gastronomie als auch beim handel einige
berliner geschäfte die man sonst
nirgendwo anders an flughäfen vorfindet
du siehst es nicht kasten aber erfüllen
bach nickt und sagt richtig das stück
was steuer gesagt hat er kann das also
sehr unterstreichen du bist jetzt am
terminal 1 gelandet klar terminal 2
macht wegen der korona pandemie wegen
der geringen passagierzahl die zu
erwarten ist erst im frühjahr auf gebt
uns doch mal ein überblick über die
terminals die überhaupt der br künftig
haben wird
ja es gibt insgesamt drei terminals
eigentlich jetzt das große das berühmte
des terminal 1 dann wurde ein terminal 2
erbaut für sechs millionen passagiere
was erstmal den krone jetzt allerdings
nicht öffnen wird
und dann gibt es das terminal 5 und
dieses terminal 5 ist der alte flughafen
schönefeld der eigentlich abgeschlossen
werden sollte
er bleibt aber erst einmal
ausgabe 05 für einige verwirrung denke
ich bei passagieren sorgen denn er ist 2
s bahn stationen entfernt und der dann
hier am ber abgehetzt am terminal 1
ankommt er könnte einen schrecken
bekommen denn am terminal 5 da fliegt
zum beispiel ryanair ab heute landen
zwei maschinen so eine art soft opening
noch mit wenigen passagieren morgen
starten dann die ersten maschinen auch
die geht es jetzt weiter purple am 9
der heute wird es abends noch in der
linien landung geben der erste pfleger
morgen früh wird nach london fliegen
hier auch von easyjet und vierter
november wird dann offiziell auch die
südbahn in betrieb genommen mit dem
ersten langstrecken flieger von qatar
airways gast während vielen dank erstmal
für deine eindrücke und für deine
informationen über den flughafen wiens
vielleicht das erste myspace passagier
und als journalist schreiten wirst ja
wenn man wie bei einer fernsehserie kurz
zusammenfassen sollte was bisher geschah
dann viel spaß denn die geschichte
dieses flughafens ist länger inzwischen
als die komplette lindenstraße zusammen
wir haben uns trotzdem versucht in einer
chronologie der wichtigsten ereignisse
1996 setzt die politik überraschend
schönefeld als standort fest 2007 soll
der neue hauptstadt-airport eröffnen
doch daraus wird nichts 2003 die
geplante privatisierung des flughafens
scheitert berlin brandenburg und der
bund nehmen den bau selbst in die hand
ein kapitalfehler das desaster nimmt
seinen lauf
2006 spatenstich der flughafen soll 2011
öffnen baukosten zwei milliarden euro
politiker fordern mehr und mehr umbauten
platz für geschäfte und größere
flugzeuge
2010 das planungsbüro für die gesamte
technik geht pleite
die eröffnung verschoben auf 2012
zweifel wisch berlins regierender
bürgermeister vom tisch bei mir
überhaupt keine sorgen weil das ist
beschlossen dass es fertig mai 2012 die
eröffnung abgeblasen
nur dreieinhalb wochen vor dem termin
offizielle begründung der brandschutz in
wirklichkeit ist der flughafen nur zu 56
prozent betriebsfähig zehntausende
mängel werden bekannt zu kurze
rolltreppen defekte türen die
brandschutzanlage unbeherrschbar neue
eröffnungstermin erst märz dann oktober
2013 zuversichtlich 2015 verschiebt der
flughafen chef die eröffnung auf 2017
und tritt ab teilweise machen
verantwortliche den abflug aber
verantwortung übernimmt keiner 2016 die
enteisungsanlage wird umgebaut
600 brandschutzwände erneuert
zehntausende kilometer kabel
ausgetauscht
wieder wackelt der termin das kann ende
17 klappen das kann anfang aktien sein
und das ist da jetzt auf eine woche oder
einen monat auch nicht mehr drauf
ankommt 2017 personalkarussell
flughafenchef nummer fünf tore müssen
endlich die baustelle fertig kriegen
eröffnung verschoben auf 2020
die kosten haben sich verdreifacht von
zwei auf sechs milliarden euro
sprechen wir über das alles mit dieter
faulenbach er ist immer noch bei uns
flughafen experte vier flughafenchef
sechs technische leiter hat man
verschließen auf dem weg zur heutigen
eröffnung ist das ursache oder folge der
chaotischen zustände eigentlich also zum
einen würde ich sagen einmal
war die ursache bei meinem vorstand
eines flughafens offensichtlich der
anforderungen an einen großflughafen den
neubau eines großflughafens nicht
geläufig waren mit seinem planungsteam
und den planern die man dabei hatte und
da grundlegende fehler gemacht hat da
hatten wir ja schon kurz darüber
gesprochen und auf der anderen seite
danach dann ein fehler beim
aufsichtsrats sich ich sag mal die
falschen leute zu holen oder den
richtigen den mann erst geholt hatten
aus frankfurt amman der erkannt hat wie
man vorgeht auf dem bau probleme suchen
probleme erkennen probleme zu weisen und
lösen und zwar in der gewährleistung
durch die baufirma dass man den relativ
schnell wieder hat gehen lassen geht
oder fährt gehen müssen und dann ein
programm aufgelegt hat das wurde dann
sprint programm genannt ich habe das
dann das trainingsprogramm genannt in
dem die baufirmen und planer aus der
pflicht der nachbesserung entlassen
worden und dienstleistungsverträge bekam
und kann erfolg geschuldet waren sondern
nun auf der baustelle anwesend sein
mussten und das war die manege die dann
ab 2013 gestartet ist bis dann
schließlich rückt 2017 gordischen knoten
durchschlagen hat und dieses problem
erkannt hat und beseitigt wird
ursache und folge das betrifft auch
insolvenzen manche insolvenzen waren
ursache für noch mehr chaos andere sind
insolvent gegangen weil es dieses chaos
gab sie haben eben laut genickt als
kasten wären zum beispiel von den
ladenbesitzern gesprochen hat die sich
eigentlich 2012 natürlich auf der
eröffnung eingerichtet hatten da
vielleicht alles reingeschmissen haben
und dann kam es doch nicht dazu
dazu wollten sie auch noch sagen ja
sehen sie die insolvenzen dieser kleinen
läden im traumland die sich jetzt auf
drei standorte verteilen auch noch das
muss man dazu sagen
und statt der erwarteten 38 140
millionen jahres passagiere müssen
wer im moment in diesem jahr mit 8
millionen rechnen ich denke da wird es
nicht viel daran ändern dass diesen
geschäften fehlen die kunden fehlen die
einnahmen fielen die umsätze und auch
dass diese kleinen privaten läden
durchhalten über längeren zeitraum wage
ich zu bezweifeln
es sei denn man lässt den die mieten die
umsatzbeteiligung
aber es wird nichts auf jeden fall nicht
dazu führen dass der flughafen einnahmen
generieren kann um dann zum flughafen
insolvenz zu kommen weil sie eben von
einem zuschauer angesprochen wurde der
flughafen hatten der öffentliche pflicht
zum betrieb er muss betrieben werden
deshalb wird der flughafen auch bei
einer insolvenz der
flughafengesellschaft nicht geschlossen
sondern der wert weiter betrieben mit
einer neuen flughafengesellschaft nur
die der unterschied ist dann dass dann
die schulden die öffentliche hand
übernehmen
dazu ein kommentar von axel wilson von
facebook man kann nur hoffen dass diese
schrott ruine von anfang an dermaßen
rote zahlen schreibt dass sie wieder
dichtmachen unfassbar dass sich dafür
keiner vor gericht verantworten musste
das ist jetzt natürlich eine sehr starke
meinung um es mal so zu sagen aber
dieses verantworten das ist ja wirklich
also zumindest keiner der großkopferten
hat bisher verantwortung übernommen
worden
das warum kann man ein mann darauf
festnehmen weil wie ich das eben mal
gesagt habe dass diese verantwortung ist
einem land aus inkompetenz
überheblichkeit fehlender aufsicht zu
viele beteiligte für viele zu viele
beteiligte und auch schlechtes
management und all diese wir wollen dass
das ist eine addition oder mit
landschaft allen das können sie kann zu
weisen
und da können sie kam nie einen
verantwortlichen finden weil jeder auf
den anderen verantwortlichen weisen
verweisen kann und im endeffekt kann der
aufsichtsrat sage ich mal die damals
politisch verantwortlich gesehen wird
ist auch richtig so aber immer darauf
verweisen wir hatten einen
geschäftsführer und der geschäftsführer
dazu unterrichtet in der
flughafen-geschäftsführer nicht mehr
glaubt dann sollen entlassen aber er
muss ihn gleich so lange im amt ist
sprechen wir gleich darüber weiter wir
schalten noch mal auf die live bilder
live zuschauer gerade da ist aufgebaut
die bühne für die vor allem für die
bauherren also der bund wird heute
vertreten von bundesverkehrsminister ja
das land brandenburg von dietmar woidke
und die stadt berlin von michael oer dem
regierenden bürgermeister und alle drei
wollen es sich natürlich nicht nehmen
lassen auch was zu sagen
schauen wir mal an wir lassen es einfach
für sie mal steht dass die situation und
die fühlst dich versehen
ja es hat sich so historisch angefühlt
wie sie es gehört ich glaube man merkte
die in dem moment und gerade für uns die
wir hier vor davor 94 jahren gegründet
wurde in berlin jetzt hier heute dabei
sein zu dürfen und das fühlte sich gut
an für die crew für die passagiere ich
hoffe die am boden auch schön hier zu
sein ein paar jahre später als geplant
aber wir freuen uns trotzdem und auch
anders als hier geplant die doppel
landung war nicht möglich sie waren
leider der zweite aber ich glaube das
ist ganz schlimm
wir haben da gern vortritt gelassen
natürlich sollte jeder der ehrengäste
hier noch einmal zu wort kommen bevor
der große moment der öffnung da ist ich
bitte alle gäste auf ihre plätze
herr spur sie dort hinten links und ute
pleased to down on the site
und das erste wort gehört natürlich dem
hausherrn engelbert lütke daldrup sehr
geehrter herr bundespräsident dr
sehr geehrter herr regierende
bürgermeister michael müller sehr geehrt
der bundesverkehrsminister andreas
scheuer
sehr geehrte präsidenten sehr geehrter
präsident wieland geehrte damen und
herren abgeordnete des bundestages des
landtages des abgeordnetenhauses peter
lundgren träger der spur
die airline auf sind natürlich die
wichtigsten heute und ich freue mich
sehr dass ich heute begrüßen kann
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
heute ist kein historischer tag
aber es ist für uns für berlin und
brandenburg für ostdeutschland ein ganz
wichtiger tag
trotz der bedrückenden pandemie freuen
wir uns alle sehr sie heute hier am
flughafen die fashion run groß diesel
und redet noch der flughafenchef
wir werden gleich mal reinhören berlin
ministerpräsidenten zu wort vom bzw der
regierende bürgermeister von berlin
schauen aber erst noch als zu unserer
reporterin nico albrecht die sich
postiert hat vor dem br denn dort gibt
es massive proteste wir haben eben schon
drüber gesprochen
nicola es gibt klimaaktivisten hast du
eben gesagt es gibt aber auch andere was
sind denn die größten anliegen der
demonstranten heute
primär geht es tatsächlich um das klima
hier einen flughafen zu eröffnen in
einer klimakrise die erderwärmung eine
große rolle spielt das halten die
menschen die hier demonstrieren für
unverantwortlich und deswegen sind auch
die meisten hier weniger vertreten sind
die anwohner die allerdings auch nicht
sehr erbaut sind über diese eröffnung
heute denn da gibt es auch mannigfaltige
probleme es wurde ja über lärmschutz
gesprochen und auch lärmschutz quasi hin
gefordert eingeklagt manche anwohner
haben davon gebrauch gemacht konnten die
kosten erstattet bekommen um ihre häuser
und wohnungen zu dämmen
andere haben davon keinen gebrauch
gemacht weil sie nicht wussten wird denn
dieser flughafen überhaupt eröffnet
lohnt es sich oder sollen wir vielleicht
doch lieber wegziehen also es ist
rundherum ehrlich gesagt sehr sehr viel
unmut und kommt auch überhaupt keine
feierstimmung auf hier neigen sich
langsam die demonstrationen und dem ende
zu
aber ich hab noch jemanden bei mir und
zwar riva modell von 2 days for future
und den würde ich ganz gerne noch mal
fragen natürlich ein bisschen hier mit
corona abstand zum einen riva morell
glauben sie wie viel erfolg oder müssen
gehört wenn sie sich heute noch
verschaffen
und gibt es nicht auch etwas positives
an diesem flughafen und an dieser
eröffnung heute
ich glaube wir haben heute relativ klar
gezeigt dass wir gegen diese führten
sind haben uns auch glaube ist relativ
breit auch kundgetan
ich sehe allerdings nicht in diesem
flughafen ist das klimapolitische im
jahr 2020 wo die klimakrise eigentlich
ja gerade eskaliert noch einen flughafen
zu eröffnen das ist einfach nicht
verantwortbar das kann nicht sein
also auch noch nicht einmal sozusagen
die gute es waren anbindung
was stimmt sie ein wenig fröhlich dass
viele sagen na ja der flughafen ist er
kaum mit dem auto zu erreichen
überall sind die autobahnen drumherum
verstopft das heißt man kommt hier gar
nicht hin man fährt immerhin mit den
öffis wie man hier so schön sagt zum
flughafen das stimmt ja auch nicht
fröhlicher naja ist halt die frage wohin
man fährt man im endeffekt ist das eben
im flughafen es kann nicht sein dass wir
irgendwie immer noch am flughafen bauen
und wir haben schon angesprochen
sie haben dafür hier eine anbindung von
öffentlichen nahverkehr aber das ist ein
ganz ganz kleiner teil und es fehlen
immer noch milliarden im öffentlichen
nahverkehr auch vor allem für die
beschäftigten
wir brauchen einen grundlegenden
verkehrs wandel und dazu gehört kein
flughafen dazu gehöre neben gelder an
die beschäftigten im öpnv
dazu gehören gelder einfach in die
infrastruktur ganz herzlichen dank dafür
[Musik]
lieber moment hat es ja eben schon
gesagt also die stimmung ist tatsächlich
hier bei den aktivisten sie willkommen
sind
so dass sie sagen flughafen geht
heutzutage einfach gar nicht mehr es
muss weniger geflogen werden
man muss andere wege finden um von a
nach b zu kommen und vielleicht auch
nicht in sechs stunden von hier auf
einen anderen kontinent
nicola wir kriegen hier auch zahlreiche
kommentare natürlich von unseren usern
zum beispiel schreibt werner gleißner
auf facebook etwas was offenbar mehrere
weg traut oft matt egl etwas hinterher
tegel zu schließen schreibt er sei
einfach nur dumm nicht nur dass nicht
wenige metropolen zwei oder mehrere
flughafen betreiben auch im hinblick auf
ausweichmöglichkeiten vorübergehende
schließungen und vielen weiteren
möglichen szenarien einen perfekt
funktioniert in den flughafen zu
schließen sei einfach nur dumm trauern
viele leute in der region tegel
hinterher der war ja auch durchaus
umstritten manche liebte ihn manche
machten ihn aber auch gar nichts
tatsächlich das ist eine weit
verbreitete meinung hier in berlin und
auch sogar in brandenburg tegel war
unglaublich beliebt weil er einfach sehr
sehr klein und sehr gut erreichbar war
und zwar aus der stadt wenn man hier zum
ber raus möchte von berlin-mitte
beispielsweise dann braucht man bei
stärkerem verkehr schon muss man
mindestens eine stunde einplanen in
tegel war man in 20 minuten
und dann dauerte check-in nicht lange
mann hatte kurze wege das war einfach
tatsächlich ein sehr beliebter kleiner
bescheidener hauptstadtflughafen wenn
man so will
keiner möchte hier raus fahren mit dem
eigenen auto dann weiß man nicht wo man
es abstellen soll
okay es gibt tatsächlich jetzt die s
bahn aber auch das ist von der anbindung
her nicht von überall aus gesehen
optimal das heißt die trauer um tegel
ist tatsächlich sehr sehr groß und
tatsächlich wenn man vergleicht mit
anderen städten es gibt natürlich viele
metropolen und hauptstädte die ihren
flugverkehr auf mehrere flughäfen
verteilen
berlin hat sich anders entschieden und
hat gesagt wir schließen tegel und
eröffnen den br also zumindest jetzt 14
jahre nach spatenstich ein riesenthema
nicola war natürlich auch der lärmschutz
habe ich eben schon mit dem flughafen
experten dieter faulenbach lange schon
darüber gesprochen
ich glaube es war eines der größten
lärmschutz verfahren überhaupt der
geschichte als damals vor dem
bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig das
verfahren lief wurden lastwagen mit
akten gesichert gesichtet zu welcher
lösung ist mit den daten gekommen und
wie befriedigt sind denn die leute da
jetzt heute oder oder gar nicht
tatsächlich ist so richtig zufriedenheit
nicht eingekehrt denn es gibt auch noch
keine abschließende lösung es gibt
teillösungen manche anwohner haben von
lern schutzprogrammen also individuellen
lärmschutz programmen sprich der
finanzierung von dämmung von häusern und
wohnungen gebrauch gemacht und andere
wiederum haben noch abgewartet weil sie
gar nicht mit der eröffnung des
flughafens gerechnet haben weil sie
vielleicht aber auch erst einmal
abwarten wollten
wie sich tatsächlich die lärmbelästigung
für sie individuell darstellt vielleicht
spekulieren auch manche anwohner in
nächster nähe noch darauf dass ihnen das
grundstück abgekauft wird oder dass
vielleicht auch jemand kaufen möchte und
tatsächlich in flughafennähe zu sein
grundsätzlich aber fühlen sich die
meisten anwohner hier in brandenburg er
im stich gelassen sind verunsichert weil
sie nicht so genau wissen was kommt
jetzt im grunde genommen hier auf sie zu
und selbst das angebot und das ja da war
dass man sagt man hat hier
möglicherweise jobs am flughafen und
dann eben wenn man hier in der nähe
wohnt eine kurze anfahrt hat nicht
wirklich als überzeugendes argument bei
den anwohnern gegolten zu sagen toll ich
wohne schon dort wo ein flughafen gebaut
wird also die sorge und der widerstand
ist immer noch sehr sehr groß und eine
befriedigende lösung für alle
beteiligten hier in der region gibt es
noch längst nicht gibt es noch leute sie
es explizit freuen ich meine sohn vor
dem flughafen kann ja auch vorteile
bringen zum beispiel bessere
verkehrsanbindung arbeitsplätze haben
sie solche stimmen auch gehört die sagen
ja super dass wir jetzt hier in der nähe
des neuen großflughafens boden weniger
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen also
tatsächlich hat mir heute morgen eine
dame erzählt die ich hier her gekommen
ist und gesagt hat endlich endlich ist
er auf und
tatsächlich profitiere ich mal davon
weil ich wohne in der nähe und mein sohn
der lebt im ausland und wenn die kommune
pandemie vorbei ist und ich wieder
fliegen kann
dann habe ich tatsächlich einen kurzen
weg aber das war eine einzelne stimme
sicherlich gibt es von diesen stimmen
vielleicht eine handvoll mehr aber es
ist nicht die überwiegende zahl der
bürger drumherum die sagt wir haben toll
jetzt gibt es den der
hauptstadtflughafen in brandenburg ein
dickerer wenige sagen hey es ist nicht
berlin das habe ich heute auch schon
gehört es ist eigentlich ein
brandenburger flughafen und darauf sind
wir ein bisschen stolz und da waren aber
die ins nikolai am nicht über am
kaffeetisch haben darauf stolz ist auf
nicola wichtig du kurz unterbrechen darf
natürlich der ministerpräsident von
brandenburg den wir jetzt anhören wollen
diesmal spricht nämlich gerade im
terminal 1 wichtig und notwendig ist für
unsere region und zweitens davon
überzeugt dass er an den start gehen
kann und an den start gehen wird und sie
kennen alle die debatten über die
letzten jahre und ich bin engelbert
lütke daldrup und rainer bretschneider
dem team und vor allen dingen den vielen
menschen die dafür gearbeitet haben dass
wir heute hier stehen können sehr sehr
dankbar dass wir es am ende geschafft
haben heute hier am 31.10 2020 diesen
flughafen eröffnen zu können
herzlichen dank an das gesamte team
die flughafen geschichte der bau dieses
flughafens hat er viele
herausforderungen ich will die ganzen
einzelne themen gar nicht aufzählen die
journalisten wissen das sehr genau ich
habe mir in den letzten tagen auch viele
rückblicke gelesen und einzelne dinge
die da diskutiert worden sind und ich
bin auch fest davon überzeugt dass der
heutige tag nicht ein tag ist wo wir
sagen können wir stehen nicht vor neuen
herausforderungen
ja ganz klar auch mit dem heutigen tag
wird es neue herausforderungen für
diesen flughafen willy brandt hier in
brandenburg geben und diese
herausforderung sind greifbar wir sind
herausforderungen die wir teilweise noch
nicht kennen aber ich kenne einige
herausholen können wir heute schon ich
denke an die demonstranten vor der tür
wir brauchen im fliegen mehr
klimaneutralität und wo wenn nicht hier
an dieser stelle hier in brandenburg und
berlin können wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen
dass fliegen klimaneutraler wird wir
sind das bundesland mit der höchsten
produktion erneuerbarer energien und wir
sind das bundesland das heute schon
daran arbeitet das wieder fliegen
endlich klimaneutraler werden kann nur
diesen weg fortzusetzen
das ist eine große herausforderung für
uns alle
es ist eine herausforderung für den
flughafen das ist aber auch eine
herausforderung für die
luftfahrtgesellschaften wir stehen da
unter immensen druck aber es hilft uns
nicht hinzugehen und zu sagen wir
fliegen alle nicht mehr
ich glaube das wäre eine antwort die zu
kurz gegriffen ist wir brauchen den
flugverkehr wir brauchen gute
verbindungen in die ganze welt und
deswegen ist dieses infrastrukturprojekt
so wichtig und wenn ich über
verbindungen in die ganze welt rede
dann geht es natürlich auch darum dass
dieser flughafen in zukunft noch stärker
interkontinental angebunden werden muss
wir brauchen da augenhöhe mit den
flughäfen frankfurt am main und münchen
und eine dritte herausforderung auch
davon konnte man in den letzten tagen
was lesen ist dass wir weiter intensiv
mit der flughafengesellschaft mit den
flughafen geschäftsführung aber auch wir
in der politik daran arbeiten müssen
diesen flughafen auch noch zu einer
stärkeren akzeptanz im direkten
flughafenumfeld zu bringen ein flughafen
wird nur erfolgreich sein können wenn er
auch von den menschen in seinem direkten
oder mittelbaren umfeld akzeptiert wird
auch das ist eine daueraufgabe für uns
auch für die kommenden monate und jahre
erfolgsgeschichte erfolgsgeschichte
flughafen ber ist in satz der wer mir
vor wie eigentlich vor wenigen stunden
noch nicht so über über den nur die
lippen gekommen
aber ich glaube dass wir gemeinsam heute
das erste kapitel schreiben eine
erfolgsgeschichte des flughafens willy
brandt und ich glaube auch gerade in
dieser corona pandemie wir sind ja alle
davon betroffenen gerade in einer zeit
wo in den nächsten tagen für viele
menschen harrte beschränkungen in berlin
und brandenburg in kraft treten werden
ist es wichtig auch dieses signal des
optimismus zu setzen
diesen flughafen heute zu eröffnen und
damit auch zu sagen wir werden aus der
pandemie gut rauskommen wir haben dafür
die richtige startbahn wir haben den
flughafen will die wand herzlichen dank
herzlichen dank dietmar woidke sie haben
ihn ja schon flughafen willy brandt
genannt sowie sich dass wolfgang thierse
gestern bei der enthüllung der
gedenkwand ja auch gewünscht hat und wir
haben erfahren dass der erste der diesen
namen laut ausgesprochen hat der
abgeordnete michael müller war und heute
zur eröffnung ist der hier als
regierender bürgermeister michael müller
und es gibt übrigens den herren auf der
linken seite gelegenheit ein bisschen
auseinander zurück wir müssen natürlich
auch hier die abstandsregeln beachten
die gelten auch auf diesen pose die
podiums vielen dank ja sehr geehrte
irgend gäste und ich begrüße über die
erwähnten hinaus auch noch alle minister
und senatorinnen und senatoren viele
parlamentarier staatssekretäre von bund
und ländern die heute hier sind meine
damen und herren ich freue mich sehr
dass auch ich sie hier heute alle
begrüßen kann
ich gebe es zu es gab in den vergangenen
jahren tage die wahl zum verzweifeln
immer wieder auch schreckensmeldungen
immer wieder rückschläge
neue herausforderungen in finanz und
personalfragen planungsunterlagen die
nicht zur verfügung stand technische
probleme die zu lösen waren
es war tatsächlich nicht immer einfach
um es ganz vorsichtig zu sagen aber ich
war von einer sache immer überzeugt es
ist richtig und wichtig diesen flughafen
weiter zu bauen ihn fertig zu bauen
es ist ein wichtiges zukunftsprojekt für
unsere region und ich sage sogar weit
über berlin brandenburg hinaus
mindestens für ganz ostdeutschland und
auch für unsere europäischen nachbarn
meine damen und herren ja dieser
flughafen ist auch ein stück
wiedervereinigungs und nachwende
geschichte wir wissen welche großen
erwartungen es gab nach dem fall der
mauer alles musste ganz schnell gehen
und viele waren sich sicher es geht auch
ganz schnell voran
offensichtlich das sehen wir auch hier
aber auch in vielen anderen bereichen
war es nötig einen weg gemeinsam
zurückzulegen auch schwierige
situationen miteinander zu meistern
ja und dinge sich auch entwickeln zu
lassen und zur wahrheit gehört hier auch
bei diesem flughafen dazu dass sich
viele dinge entwickelt haben und bewusst
auch so entschieden werden mussten denn
über die kosten
steigerung wenn überbau zeiten
gesprochen wird gehört zur wahrheit mit
dazu dass heute hier ein ganz anderer
flughafen gebaut ist als er vor jahren
geplant war fast das doppelte an
quadratmetern wurde inzwischen verbaut
wir haben anforderungen der airlines
bekommen die zu berücksichtigen waren es
gab sicherheitsauflagen ja auch durch
die weltweite krise situation auch die
hier zu berücksichtigen waren ja das
gehört alles mit zur wahrheit dazu und
ich glaube wir haben jetzt ein flughafen
einen wunderbaren flughafen mit einer
ästhetik mit einer ansprechenden
architektur mit für diese größenordnung
immer noch vergleichbar kurzen wegen der
viele passagiere begeistern wird und der
glaube ich für die airlines auch eine
gute weiterentwicklung möglichkeit in
die zukunft bietet ja meine damen und
herren ist es auch tatsächlich in dieser
situation in der erneuten krise dieser
corona krise nicht einfach einen
flughafen zu eröffnen
eine situation mit der sich alle welt
weit auseinander zu setzen haben und die
insbesondere für die fluggesellschaften
natürlich für hotellerie und gastronomie
insgesamt für die wirtschaft eine große
belastung darstellt ich glaube aber wir
haben alle chancen in berlin und
brandenburg mit diesem flughafen sogar
gestärkt aus dieser krise zu gehen
wir haben einen hochmodernen einen
leistungsfähigen flughafen
wir haben diesen flughafen jetzt
eröffnet in einer wachsenden in einer
boomenden metropolen region
der flughafenchef hat das eben schon
angesprochen die ansiedlungserfolge der
letzten jahre in berlin und brandenburg
zeigen doch was es für
zukunftserwartungen und
zukunftshoffnungen an diesen standort
gibt und dazu gehört ein
leistungsfähiger flughafen ja dazu
gehört auch ein leistungsfähiger
flughafen mit den entsprechenden
anbindungen mit direct langstrecken
direkt fluganbindung die natürlich sich
auch in der nächsten zeit entwickeln
müssen
meine damen und herren ja bleibe auch
dabei es ist tatsächlich ein
zukunftsprojekt das uns viele chancen
bietet
ich will hinzufügen dass wir damit
natürlich in berlin auch viele chancen
und erwartungen verbinden ganz konkret
auch durch die schließung von tegel
ich weiß wie vielen menschen das herz
blutet wenn tegel in allernächster zeit
geschlossen wird und das muss man offen
und er
ich sagen so einen innerstädtischen
flughafen mit diesen kurzen wegen wird
es weltweit nie wieder geben das stimmt
aber er ist eben kein flughafen der
zukunft
er konnte schon in den letzten jahren
nicht mehr das bieten was eigentlich
nötig ist was die flughafengesellschaft
was die fluggesellschaften brauchen für
ihre entwicklung was auch die passagiere
erwarten an service an infrastruktur und
dienstleistungen das konnte in tegel
nicht mehr geboten werden und erst recht
könnte es für die zukunft nicht mehr
geboten werden und wir in berlin haben
jetzt die chance auch indem wir diese
belastung dieses innerstädtischen
verkehrs rausnehmen ein zukunfts ort zu
entwickeln gewerbeansiedlung
investitionen arbeitsplätze werden
mitten in der stadt möglich sein und
werden uns und den berlinerinnen und
berliner in vielen unternehmen und
vielen partnern in aller welt auch ganz
neue chancen bieten
meine damen und herren ich möchte ich
möchte mich bei allen bedanken die das
möglich gemacht haben
natürlich vor allen dingen hier auch das
team vor ort das team in tegel und das
team hier vor ort das geholfen hat das
so umzusetzen
ich sage ganz offen ich freue mich sehr
dass ich auch mithelfen konnte genau
dieses team mit zusammenzustellen dass
hier im vorstand dieses projekt so zu
ende führt das eben das projekt und die
fertigstellung des flughafens in den
mittelpunkt stellt und nicht sich selbst
ich glaube dass das ein erfolgsgeheimnis
war der letzten jahre dass hier ganz
klar prioritäten gesetzt wurden dafür
ein großes dankeschön dass das gelungen
ist mit diesem team ich bedanke mich bei
den fluggesellschaften die in
schwierigen phasen dabei geblieben sind
und gesagt haben
wir glauben wir glauben an diesen
standort berlin und brandenburg wir
glauben an diesen flughafen bedanke mich
bei den hoteliers bei den
geschäftsleuten die bittere zeiten hier
in den letzten jahren miteinander zu
bewältigen hat noch nicht zuletzt auch
bei den bauarbeitern gerade die die in
den letzten jahren mitunter fehler der
vergangenheit die für die sie nicht
verantwortung getragen haben hier in
ordnung gebracht haben
lieber engelbert lütke daldrup ich
möchte mich ganz persönlich bei dir
bedanken
alle wissen dass wir uns lange und gut
kennen
und ich habe eben ein team gewürdigt
aber an der spitze eines teams muss
immer jemand stehen der das auch lenkt
und leitet und den ganzen eine
entsprechende richtung gibt und insofern
ist der dank natürlich mit den
glückwünschen zum geburtstag heute auch
für dich verbunden und die frage war was
kann man dir schenken
ich glaube das größte geschenk für dich
selbst ist dass wir hier gemeinsam heute
diesen tag erleben und ich wollte mir
auch verkneifen die irgendetwas mit
flugzeugen geschweige denn was lustiges
mit flugzeugen zu schenken
insofern habe ich dir mitgebracht eine
hommage an willy brandt ein kleines foto
buch über willy brandt mit fotos seines
lebensweges und ganz bewusst habe ich
das auch ausgesucht weil ich mich sehr
darüber freue wie wir gestern den
namensgeber dieses flughafens auch
würdigen konnten und wie diese
gedenktafel gemeinsam von uns enthüllt
werden konnte ja willy brandt hat auf
seinem ganzen politischen und privaten
lebensweg immer gesagt die begegnung das
kennenlernen des menschen voneinander
und miteinander lernen dass sie einen
weg zusammen gehen und dass sie eine
gute gemeinsame lösung suchen um
probleme zu lösen das ist das wichtige
frieden und freiheit das ist das
wichtige und das kommt genau aus der
begegnung und aus dem kennenlernen und
dafür steht ein flugzeug besteht ein
flughafen dass menschen fliegen können
dass sie sich begegnen können andere
länder andere kulturen andere religionen
kennen lernen daraus etwas lernen und
zurück kommen und gemeinsam einen guten
weg finden tatsächlich wolfgang thierse
hat recht hätte für diesen flughafen für
diese region für die stadt berlin eine
weltoffene freie und tolerante stadt
eine stadt der freiheit hätte es keinen
besseren namensgeber geben können in
diesem sinne danke ich mich bei allen
die das möglich gemacht haben dass wir
diesen tag wie heute so gemeinsam feiern
und ich wünsche allen für die zukunft
viel erfolg
[Applaus]
vielen dank michael müller der flughafen
eröffnet
und das konnte keiner voraussehen in
einer ganz ganz schwierigen zeit aber er
eröffnet und wir freuen uns auch
verkehrsminister andreas scheuer dabei
zu haben herrscht sie haben das wort ja
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe teilnehmer dieser
eröffnungsveranstaltung normalerweise
wäre die anrede gewesen hohe
festversammlung wir kennen die gründe
dass es jetzt anders ist es ist auch
kein jubeltag
es ist ein arbeitstag mit sehr viel
erleichterung und vorfreude
ich möchte nach 60 jahren tegel dem team
in tegel herzlich dann wir haben in den
letzten jahren ein weltwunder gesehen
mit diesem flughafen so viele passagiere
abzufertigen ist ein wirkliches
weltwunder gewesen und dafür meinen
herzlichen dank an das team in tegel und
jetzt müssen wir durchstarten in eine
zeit der zuversicht und in ein
eigentlich nächstes wirtschaftswunder
denn wir hoffen dass wir schnell aus
dieser zeit der korona pandemie
rauskommen um durchzustarten im wahrsten
sinne des wortes 30 jahre
wiedervereinigung und über bürgermeister
ich hab dann herr lüdke daldrup es ein
größeres buch gegeben
auch ein fotoband und da ging es
eigentlich um das wieder
vereinigungsministerium nämlich das
verkehrsministerium mit den vielen
projekten zur deutschen einheit
verkehrsprojekte deutsche einheit sind
so ein symbol vielleicht ist das auch
ein symbol der wiedervereinigung in der
infrastruktur sie haben es beschrieben
zurecht und herr lüdke daldrup meinen
herzlichen glückwunsch persönlich zu
ihrem geburtstag
aber ich muss ihnen sagen ich war im
april
2018 ein paar tage nach meinem
amtsbeginn hier und ich war geschockt
ich bin unten rein gekommen
sie decken alle offen die kabel hängen
runter keine rolltreppe ging und wir
haben uns in ihrem büro
nach einem blitz oder
überraschungsbesuch sehr tief in die
augen geschaut und sie haben gesagt
unser termin steht und wir halten den
versprochen und sie haben ihn gehalten
und dafür ihnen persönlich und ihrem
team einen aller herzlichsten dank und
glückwunsch
der br hat uns verärgert enttäuscht
bewegt aber jetzt jetzt dürfen wir uns
auch freuen dass auch an den start geht
und da sonst netz geht
die zeit der jobs über den br muss jetzt
schluss sein muss jetzt zu ende sein
jetzt müssen wir die zuversicht und den
mut nehmen dass wir einen flughafen
haben der ministerpräsident natürlich
auch war die strukturpolitische
bedeutung hat und wir reden nicht nur
herr spuren von den piloten und von den
top managern sondern wir reden von den
bodenabfertigung von dem personal an den
sicherheitsschleusen mit denen die hier
als urlauber es einfach wohl aber mit
ihrer familie wegfliegen die die mich
angesprochen haben in tegel und gesagt
haben ist denn auch mein arbeitsplatz
draußen der bär sicher und denen können
wir jetzt perspektive geben auch unter
strukturpolitischen gesichtspunkten und
ich glaube das ist auch die botschaft
was willy brandt sagen wollte und auf
dieser waren steht nämlich mobilität hat
auch was mit freiheit zu tun
er hat diese sätze sicherlich unter
anderen zeitgeist und einer anderen zeit
erscheinung formuliert aber es geht
schlichtweg bei der mobilität um
und deswegen ist auch dieser willy
brandt flughafen mit allen
verkehrsträgern und verkehrsmitteln
angebunden damit wir
verkehrsträgerübergreifend denken damit
wir natürlich unsere klimaziele fest im
blick haben und es gibt beim
luftverkehrs gipfel nächste woche darum
dass wir der luftverkehrs wirtschaft in
deutschland eine absolute perspektive
gehen mit so viel hunderttausenden von
arbeitsplätzen die daran hängen mit so
einer strukturpolitische bedeutung mit
so einer wichtigkeit für den
wirtschaftsstandort und natürlich auch
unter dem strukturpolitischen aspekt
müssen wir in dieser corona krise
struktur erhalten schützen und stützen
von dem flugzeugbauer mit großen
innovationen und fortschritten bis hin
zu dem der seinen laden seinen shop hier
am flughafen hat müssen wir das gesamte
system denken und deswegen sind wir in
großer verantwortung es geht um
fortschritt innovation und zukunft
und mit dieser eröffnung in ganz
schwierigen zeiten haben wir sogar das
wirklich richtige datum gesetzt was
mobilität in den letzten jahrzehnten für
deutschland ist nämlich der grundpfeiler
für wohlstand und entwicklung
und deswegen bin ich sehr froh dass wir
jetzt da sind und jetzt eben heute bitte
nicht ums geld wir reden darüber dass
wir dran arbeiten herr lüdke daldrup
dass dies wirklich ein internationales
drehkreuz wird dafür werden wir alles
tun und jetzt diesen flughafen diesen
standort in unserer bundeshauptstadt
weiterentwickeln und da gibt es genug zu
tun und deswegen freut mich dass die
airlines da sind dass die passagiere da
sind die hoffentlich einen angenehmen
flug hatten und vor allem dass das ganze
was uns ausmacht in der
luftverkehrsbranche wieder auf die füße
kommt und durchstarten kann
und da würde ich mich freuen wenn sie
als medienvertreter jetzt diesen
flughafen die deutsche
luftverkehrsindustrie die deutsche
luftverkehrswirtschaft positiv begleiten
weil es hat verdammt viel mit unserem
wohlstand in schwierigen zeiten
zu tun hier erfolgreich zu sein alles
gute starten sie durch
sie haben geliefert liefern sie weiter
entwickeln sie weiter alles gute einen
guten flug
vielen dank andreas scheuer apropos mit
freude durchstarten
ja da geht die feier natürlich weiter
das war der bundesverkehrsminister
andreas scheuer der von einer
perspektive spricht für den luftverkehr
und der jetzt zusammen mit den beiden
vertretern von brandenburg und berlin
mit ministerpräsident wolle und michael
müller auf einen großen basar drücken
wird vielleicht sehen sie die bilder
schon im hintergrund
das wird jetzt gleich passiert und das
ist dann der ganz offizielle start alle
drei haben sich also sehr optimistisch
gezeigt und werden jetzt sicherlich auch
sehr optimistisch auf ihren jeweiligen
knopf drücken genau achten sie auch
weiterhin auf die abstände genau 150 ja
hamburg erlebt ob das ist ganz im moment
eher lohnt können
herr spur der flughafen berlin
brandenburg willy brandt braucht sie und
sie brauchen auch den br
lassen sie uns den flughafen zu einem
gemeinsamen erfolg machen
[Musik]
machen
der flughafen ber ist offen und zum
abschluss müssen möchte sich der
vorsitzende des aufsichtsrats der
flughafengesellschaft bretschneider ist
natürlich auch unser signal das war ja
dann die feierliche eröffnung herrscher
durfte nicht mit drücken ich korrigiere
mich jetzt war der flughafen chef und
herrscher er wird es verkraften
faulenbach da costa wir haben jetzt viel
gesprochen über probleme die drei herren
zeigen sich natürlich entsprechend
optimistisch machen wir es mal kurz wir
wissen es gibt noch probleme allein
schon durch corona aber was wünschen sie
denn dem br jetzt für den start ich
würde den bayern natürlich wünschen dass
er das was an hoffnungen eben formuliert
wurde ein internationales drehkreuz zu
werden auch eintrifft nur dafür müsste
die flughafengesellschaft auch die
voraussetzungen schaffen das ist das
wird im moment mit den vorliegenden
planung wird das sicher nicht aber ich
wünsche ihnen dass sie das hinkriegen
und ich denke dass man sich dann auch
mal wieder über den flughafen system
gedanken machen muss um den lärm besser
zu verteilen als wenn ihnen heute
konzentriert am flughafen ber hat ein
persönliches und positives schlusswort
dankeschön dieter faulenbach da costa
für ihre expertise heute wir schließen
uns natürlich den wünschen an hoffen
dass alles jetzt gut läuft pannenfrei
dass es auch mit dem finanziellen klappt
und vor allem dass alles sicher bleibt
wir danken für euer interesse fürs
zuschauen und sagen noch einen schönen
samstag
[Musik]